（ビートボックス）
はははは↑
まあダイチさんはビートボクシングが得意で
まあいつもボクシングばっかりしている訳なんですけども、
たまにはね僕らしい動画もやろうということで
ダイチさんちょっとストップ
ダ）そういう感じ？
そうですよ
まあダイチさんはいつも
ボクシングばっかりやってる訳なんですけど
今日はたまには、
ボクシングじゃないこともねやってみようという訳で、
僕らしい企画を今日は
ダイチさんと一緒にや、ろうと思います。
ダ）うぁはははｗ
二人であるものを食べようと思ってるんですけども、
まだダイチさんにはそれを教えてません。
実際に触ってもらって
それを何かをとりあえず当ててもらいます。
（いきなりのビートボックス）
ダ）まだ？
あうんすいません今出しま～す
お～いしょー
ちょっと待ってよｗｗ
ダ）ヒィー。
こちらをね、
ダイチさんと食べていこうと思います。
ダ）それは何？グロ...い、生き物？
生き物です。
ダ）え？
ダ）まだい、生きてるの？
生きてます今。
ダ）しゃちょーも食べるんでしょでも？
僕も食べますよ
二人で、食べ切りましょ
ヤバいんすよ、
大きさが。
ダ）美味しいのそれは？
美味しいです美味しいです。
ダ）あ、じゃあ。
今、カゴから出すとこなんで。
ダ）カゴｗｗカゴｗｗ
ダ）カゴ？
触ってちょっと、当ててみてください。
ダ）触る？
触ってください。
ダ）えっ？
生き物なんで大丈夫っすよ
もうちょい上の方が
ダ）えっ？逆？
ここら辺ですね
ダ）あ、この辺？
ダ）全然下の方だったんだ
ダ）えっ？これ？
それです
あ逃げた逃げた
ダ）えっえっ？
ダ）スイカじゃん
え何で分かったんすか！？
ダ）えっ？本当にスイカ？
ダ）だははふふふｗｗ
何かアルマジロと間違えるかと思っちゃって
ダ）えこれまってｗ重くない？
重いっすよ
ダ）これ二人...胃の中に入る？
これ食べましょう二人で。
はいという訳で、
今回はこの、巨大なスイカを、
ピートビクスーのダイチすんと食べていこうと思います。
（拍手）
純粋に割っていきましょうか！
ダ）おお
ダ・は）わーーー！
はい、という訳で
割れたので、
はい、ちゃんと残さず食べていこうと
思います！
ダ）オモイマ～ス
（メ～ン）
（メーーー↑）
行きましょぉう！
ダ）え？このまま？
ダ・は）美味い。
ダ）えっｗ
ダ）ちょっと今一口食べた感じからして
ダ）これ何口かなって今計算...
ダ）んまい！
美味いですよ。
ダ）塩かけたい。
塩ぉ！
塩。
ダ）え？何これ、タイムアタック？
ダ）こんなにかけて食うの？
塩かけて美味しいんすよ
ダ）大丈夫、美味しいよ普通にこれ本当に。
じゃ。
ｗｗｗ
ダ）はははははは、ははは。
ダイチさんから言われたら食べる
ダ）えっへｗ
手で食うのは時間かかるので
スプーンで食べようと思います。
ダ）ぷっ
いただきま～す
ダ）いただきま～す
めっちゃ食いやすいねこれ
ダ）本当？
ブルドーザーみたいな感じか。
ダイチさん、ここでじゃあ
ちょっとスイカをテーマにしたビートボックスを。
ダ）えっ？
ダ）ゲホゲホ、
ダ）えへははははははｗｗ
ダ）でもさ、良く見たらさ、
ダ）しゃちょーの方がちょっとさ、深いね。
そうなんすよ、ちょっと
明らかこっちの奴がよく見たら。
ダ）ｗｗｗｗ
ダ）これキッツイな結構。
ダ）スイカジュース...
ダ）えふふふふふふあはははは。
ダ）上手いねえ
いやわざとじゃないんですよ
ダ）大物YouTuberってさ、上手いよねこういう...
違うんすよわざとじゃない...
えダイチさんこっそり僕の所に入れたりしないでくださいよ。
えこっそり入れたりしないでくださいよ...
ダ）うん、大丈夫。
（ベッチャ。）
ダ）お帰り。
はぁ
呼吸が苦しくなってきちゃった。
ダ）何かアガってくるよね、こう。
ハイになりますよね。
ウォーターメロナーズハイですねこれね。
ダ）んふ。
あれ
そ～れ～だ～け～で
ダ・は）お～も～い～では～
ダ・は）い～つ～も
ダ・は）き～れ～い～だ～けど～
そ～れ～だ～け～じゃ～お～な～
ダ・は）か～が～す～く～わ
ラストで～す
ダ）お腹痛い、う。
ダ・は）せーの
（拍手）
ダ）いや～
ダ）もうやりたくないえへへ
夏はスイカの食い過ぎに要注意だ。
ダ・は）See you next
ダ・は）beeeeeee
ダ）じゃあな
エ"ッ